this is a production of Cornell
University
hey everybody welcome back to the
Cornell Turf Show we've been sort of in
and out last couple weeks but we'll get
going back on the horse here for this
week and next week to uh to finish off
our spring almost almost summer season
now
um today's guest Dr Bill croyser uh bill
is the uh founder of green keeper app
bill I don't know if that's the the
exact right term but Bill also manages
the Jamaica golf course which we're
talking about pre-show some of the
greens there and and uh some competitive
tournaments tournaments uh playing on
those fast greens up there in Nebraska
so we'll get the we'll get some some
bills thoughts today on and probably
using data on some of the management
tactus heat tactics he's really sort of
pioneered and developed now that that
people can actually use the practical
application of these things so I will
get to a conversation with Bill in a bit
uh but I'll hand it off to Frank uh for
some of the opening thoughts today well
we had a little event up here uh last
week I'm not sure everybody knew uh not
far from where I sit uh Corcoran and the
crew at Oak Hill Country Club delivered
uh absolutely spectacular PGA
Championship and I know firsthand what
that feels like as I was intimately
involved in the 2019 PGA Championship uh
down at Bethpage it's an enormously
exciting experience of course the the
tweeting from the staff and and and and
then of course this guy uh absolutely
lit the place on fire uh and I think
rejuvenated a fair amount of interest uh
in golf again for a lot of people and
and big shout out to Groton native and
former uh employee of the Robert Trent
Jones Golf Course Jeff Corcoran a local
guy uh who who's uh now made Oak Hill uh
his uh somewhat permanent residence and
uh I think all of us in this business
really marveled particularly at the
grass around the bunkers uh I know at
Bethpage with the large bunkers there uh
managing at Bluegrass managing that Turf
around those bunkers uh gets really uh
gets really hard and I thought and the
crew did a spectacular job but on a
serious note
is Harriman down in the Mid-Atlantic uh
posted a tweet about some skin cancer
and of all places behind his ear right
you wouldn't think that'd be necessarily
a place but where those bucket hats uh
listen uh sun exposure as we get into
the season is is a big deal it's a a
part of the hazard a a a work uh Place
Hazard associated with this line of work
so just a shout out there Carl before I
pass it on to you that Safety First and
I know you've got a
um a rant here about uh uh pesticide use
reduction and let's hear it
yeah so Frank we've had these
conversations uh with our New York State
Park Golf Course superintendents for
many years uh they are focused on
obviously providing uh playing
conditions for for uh their players that
that reach a certain level every day uh
but being state parks they're interested
in in the products they're applying and
trying to reduce that as much as they
can while still maintaining uh those
playability thresholds so we talk a lot
about hey what's our pesticide use we
measure pesticide risk and one of the
big things we've learned over the years
we've published a couple articles on
this now is that uh your pests set
applications to the larger areas of the
golf course the fairways and the rough
uh really sort of add up when it comes
to the total pounds of pesticide use or
the total risk compared to Greens right
we treat greens a lot more often but hey
if we've only got three acres of greens
and 30 Acres of Fairways right the
pesticide use on those larger areas is
really sort of what drives pesticide
risk so today I wanted to talk about
some of the the sort of the IPM tenets
we've used with State Park
superintendents how we you've gotten to
reduce risk over the years first one
scouting right whether you're doing
these check plots I love the checkpots
bills I always tweeting about some of
his checkpots you can see hey is the
pest present or hey what did this
product get me when I had applied it and
that's a really good way to figure out
if it's worth it to apply it right so
you see a couple here from some folks
looking at disease and hey those
applications we made work so that's how
you know the disease is present you also
got to know maybe the timing of
application Ben McGraw just had him on
the show last week right he was telling
us some of the data he looks at
phenological indicators are really good
indicators of ABW progression over the
year and how you treat that he just
tweeted the other day about the larvae
coming up right on schedule right so all
that's based on scouting and data so now
we have data like Ben's talking about
Growing Degree Days phenological
indicators this up on the screen is the
Smith Kearns Dollar spot model right so
now we have these pest pressure models
that are pretty good maybe at figuring
out when this pest is going to come
uh and require treatment so what we'd
say is hey use that data and just
monitor right monitor that data use your
indicator areas use your scouting and
try and pair that to figure out how you
can use that data in the future right so
Smith currents L if it's at 26 and I see
dollar spot okay notice that over time
log that and you'll start to look for
those Trends uh so now okay you can do
some of those things you can get to
pesticide reductions just doing some of
those practices but uh one thing we're
looking at now with our state parks is
let's incorporate some technology there
right GPS sprayers uh we did some work
with skinny Atlas Country Club a few
years back looked at their product usage
before and after they put a frost ink
sprayer on on their existing unit and
they saw reductions Fairway product used
about 15 greens was a little bit higher
30 percent rough about 10 so you're
looking at across the course 15 to 20
product savings that means less
pesticide use that's really good no
surprise why that happens right you
eliminate the overlaps you eliminate the
the sort of triangles on the edge you're
trying to stick a square peg into a
round hole essentially with the manual
sprayer so that's a really easy way some
low hanging fruit you obviously got to
make some Investments for that and that
helps you spot treat so another
interesting thing I've picked up on over
the years Paul Coke at UW Madison and
their University Ridge Golf Course set
up these weather monitoring stations on
two different holes the 9th and 18th
holes and they consistently measured 15
higher dollar spot pressure on their
18th hole which is really sort of this
wall of trees sort of restricting air
movement and shading that Fairway
compared to the night pole which is way
out in the open a lot of air movement
right so if you're treating these
Fairways you know five six times a year
maybe for something like Dollar spot hey
does that nine pole always need that
dollar spot spray maybe that's something
to think about okay that's maybe four
acres you can start cutting some some
product usage down and then I love this
image Bill this uh you tweeted this out
maybe a couple months ago but uh
basically for those who can't see this
is a GPS application you can sort of
look back on Google Maps hey where did I
make this application this Incorporated
a lot of things right you can see
there's only specific parts of the golf
course that get this application in the
rough couple T's it's not widespread
right so there's some scouting involved
there I think Bill
um so you're using some data that looks
like a pre-emergent application here for
for nutsedge uh you can see that initial
application sort of in purple and then
there's sort of a pink application which
looks like a post-emergent sort of touch
up again using scouting and that's even
a smaller area so this really
incorporates a lot of the things we we
love to see when it comes to pesticide
use reduction and and controlling those
pests really effectively right where is
the pest when is it present combining
all those IPM tactics and Technology to
uh to reduce our product and pesticide
usage so so Bill does frost sprayer
generate this image or do you have to
draw it good question so let's just say
how this happened so nut Sage is
something that we know we get better
control right as this emerging using
post-emergence it's a perennial warm
season grass or instead sorry and so
when it pops up you need to go out with
some of the different chemistries I
think I've used sedge Hammer the last
couple years if you wait until you see
it everywhere your control is bad so in
year one which is now three years ago we
were later early June really obvious
marginal control but then in the
subsequent years we've used that map
from the first year to then roughly draw
out where we see it so instead of
targeting 30 Acres of rough I'm just
hitting now three acres of where I've
saw it last year and then by doing that
over and over this really tough
perennial weed it used to be widespread
is now being minimized through three
years of targeted applications right
where it is hitting the same spots and
so it's a little bit darker intense
purple that's where we made a second
application where we saw some
breakthrough and so
um all the GPS sprayers like the one
from Frost they can export their shapes
and so you can see exactly where you
sprayed and then in Greenkeeper now
we're actually being able to import
those and then draw boundaries right
um in those spots so that you could even
just send someone out they just drive
around and they just automatically hit
all these areas because you can look
down at it see what you sprayed last
year you know make Target those spots
we've even made it out too so that you
can drive around in your golf cart and
circle weed areas or pest areas and make
real-time polygons so that you can make
targeted sprays for things like spring
dead Spa weeds any type of pest that is
perennial and it's at a pretty similar
location and therefore really reduce the
amount of product you're applying this
is great bill so listen let me get
through some weather because I got some
pgr stuff to talk about and I'm always
apologetic for taking you away from the
pgrs for a few years to come and study
with us here uh and then uh so glad that
you got back at it now listen everybody
in the Northeast has been pretty aware
that we're still on the cool side it was
a cooler than normal week uh last week
which you know I think in many ways has
slowed growth almost as much as the dry
conditions so a little bit cooler than
normal uh soil temperatures continue to
stay in the high 50s low 60s uh
particularly along the coast it started
to cool off obviously the two inch soil
temperatures are going to respond to the
air temperatures pretty uniformly so you
know we're still seeing a slowing of the
progression of the growing season and
again as a measure the real story is how
dry it's been now East uh of New York
State and into New England particularly
in Southeastern New England Connecticut
and Rhode Island along the cape got a
lot of rainfall we stayed pretty much on
the dry side here we had a little bit of
rain of course everybody that watched
Oak Hill for a couple of days over the
weekend saw the persistent rain that
they got and you can see in this
particular image if you're watching on
NewsChannel 8 here that uh that rainfall
was really localized in the Rochester
area but because there was no heat and
electricity associated with it they just
played right through and obviously those
wonderfully coarse sand greens that they
uh redid when Andrew Green went in there
and redid the place uh drained
exceptionally well when you look at
overall deficits you're starting to see
a pretty good deficit start to form uh
in the metropolitan New York area and
really throughout the Northeast really
the only wet spot left is in the
mountains of West Virginia so so dry
continues to be the story and I'm and
you know uh that's looks like it's going
to persist except we're going to get
quite a bit warmer there's there's
pretty widespread agreement that we're
going to be 10 to 12 degrees above
normal next week well into the 80s uh
almost every day so we're gonna have the
temperatures in place uh the question is
you know are we going to get the growth
now just a note because we had Ben last
week talking abw's uh Albert copenhofer
uh from Rutgers made a comment about
larval conditions rhododendrons you know
you ought to be looking to make your
larvicide applications uh if you haven't
done that yet but I thought in his blog
post the particular language around
pyrethroid existing populations
larvicides behave differently depending
on whether you've had a high level of
pyrethroid resistance or not and there's
a variety of products available to trino
but not soprato soprato soprato not
available in New York State uh tetrino
is available farins and match point also
available uh Provence might be a better
choice for highly pyrethroid resistant
populations and again dry weather we're
not sure how it's going to affect ABW
but we all know annual Bluegrass doesn't
necessarily like dry weather so this may
lead to some increased injury now seed
head flushes out and about on the golf
course I was out in East Aurora country
club on Monday and you can tell we're in
major seed head flush right now so Bill
I gotta tell you I'll bring you in here
you just sort of tweeted this this
morning really appreciate it I was so
happy to see this now available in
Canada part of what I wanted to focus on
with you today was a new and honestly
I've been out of the game a little bit
here I was not aware that it knew it
wasn't effective product for seed head
suppression
um I don't know if it works alone but
you've got some data here you and
Kaminsky just a couple of years ago did
some work looking at a new first seed
head suppression can you take a minute
and talk a little bit about a new and
Seed head suppression yeah it's um I
think it's still a little bit of an
unknown
um in this here we still have a new with
proxy just like you would use a new
Prima with proxy so the proxy is still
your bigger driver but as one of our
colleagues that have sold at he was
applying a new at a course on Madison
last year without proxy and still seeing
pretty good control and so there's some
data out there it's not consistent but
just like proxy is not consistent this
year
um you know I hit my timings I didn't
get a fall app which was really
important because we went from like 85
in middle of October to like 30 and the
end of October and it was just that
wasn't in the cards and my control was
was pretty bad this year but then the
courses down next door that made the
fall app had great control right so the
timings are probably important and it's
probably similar with the new and so I
think there's a lot more we need to
learn about what a new alone would do
for for seed head but it is a good
reason to consider Anew with with proxy
um I though do like to do proxy by
itself though first app when because
usually your first half the grass is
just breaking dormancy and then come in
with a new proxy maybe on your second
app 200 Growing Degree Days basically
later so so you know Canada I mean I
thought this was a a wow because Canada
doesn't have proxy or Embark or any of
these other things so if if a new turns
out to be on its own something you can
put out in the fall like a proxy app and
then uh maybe in the spring that's going
to be a big deal for for Canada now
listen annual Bluegrass when it starts
flowering and this is all pres you know
uh you know speculative From alturgeon's
perspective you know when when you get
this seed head flush you get a cessation
in rooting as he would speculate here
now annual Bluegrass has a more uniform
growth rate uh during the season at
least theoretically Bank Grass uh a much
slower to get going although I will say
uh I saw a lot of bent grass going
earlier this year and I think some of it
was because the proxy just knocks the
crap out of the annual Bluegrass and you
can see the creeping bent grass uh
sneaking through so Bill as we
transition to growth I always start out
with growth potential I know it's not
everybody's favorite thing on a weekly
or daily basis but over the course of
the year you can see if we're going to
average looks like we're going to
average in the low 60s this coming week
uh it's still going to get cool at night
but be really warm during the day you're
really getting towards where the growth
potential model indicates you're going
to get maximum growth now with maximum
growth when you start hard to collect
clippings Carl's done this a number of
years now you know where you can see the
bottom lines here are more uniform a
little bit less blipping uh probably
some growth regulator use on on these
greens and and the and the green line
above maybe not a good pgr use I know
that's a very similar line that we see
at the Vineyard Golf Club where they
can't use uh growth Regulators uh out
there so uh Bill uh just so that
everybody knows a good primer I know
it's old now it's probably eight years
old you wrote this article back in 2015.
it's still probably one of the more
comprehensive articles we can find If
people really want to understand the
effective use of growth Regulators so I
I don't know if you have anything newer
than that but the thing that jumped out
at me and what I wanted to chat with you
about is I'm hearing the sales folks are
getting good now at getting people on
the new I think at first people were
like you know Primo Primo premium I like
Primo I like what I get and then you
know they started to say well maybe you
don't have to treat as much and you look
at your uh you know Growing Degree day
model here and I I guess essentially
what you'd say is it it it it pretty
much you know lasts longer and again in
your green keeper app you've done a
spectacular job in really helping people
if they're able to collect clippings and
make routine applications looking at the
overall growth regulation you're going
to get from something like a new with a
little bit of trim it and then a lot of
guys are putting their summer patch and
wrenches on now with dmis and you're
gonna get that you know additional
growth regulation associated with it
today and so what you've done
exceptionally well is saying okay use
all these things individually you get
this collectively you can get 60 to 70
percent uh gross suppression which you
know know you start getting a lot of
traffic especially in walk-on walk-off
areas and you're getting 60 suppression
you might start to see some thinning in
the highest traffic areas now Bill the
thing I'm most excited about is this uh
machine learning business where you're
looking at predicting growth based on
weather predicting growth looking at
nitrogen and traffic uh predicting
growth adding a sensor and we're going
to work with you this year putting one
of the sensors on our mowers out at rtj
and then ultimately the goal is I would
hope to get to this point in your
Greenkeeper app where you can put this
data in get some of this additional data
start to train the machine to be able to
predict what's going to happen every day
maybe even without taking the data
anymore I I know ultimately that's going
to be your goal here but let's start the
conversation with the new
um you know guys like mixing you know I
like I put a little new I put some primo
and and you know uh you know you got
Three Musketeer you got all the
different types of combinations that are
out there how do you talk about how do
you talk about a new uh to people who
might not have used it before and the
kinds of responses and performance
you're seeing with it well I think
generally we think about the different
grass pieces on your bent POA surfaces
at Green's height it lasts a little bit
longer and you get a little bit more
suppression than say your Primo in
Fairway height grasses are very similar
uh to each other
um and then it also into your Athletic
Field Heights Supreme on a new seem to
work about the same you go into the
Bermuda grass warm season uh arena in
the Anew actually lasts half as long
which has worked well because a lot of
times in those environments people like
to make weekly or more frequent
applications and so that shorter lasting
and new leads to less over regulation
because you're not doing what you termed
initially is stacking or this kind of
accumulation so every species is
different and we're doing this work for
Anew and now for all the dmis uh we're
doing in the warm season uh research
areas this year with uh Kearns and and
Chase straw and Seashore pastelum and
Zoysia and Bermuda grass to really
understand how all of these products are
working but ultimately every grass every
active ingredient Works differently
a benefit of mixing though is you get an
additive effect so if you increase the
rates of these pgrs you're going to see
more suppression sometimes the label's
so restrictive you really can't increase
rate much so in order to get more
suppression you have to start layering
on them on top of each other so I've
used Anew and trim it at my golf course
to really suppress the growth rate I do
a new at a flat standard eight ounce
rate and then I'll vary my trim it rates
based on the performance of my turf so
if I'm seeing a lot of growth I'll go up
12 16 ounces of trim it if I'm seeing
low growth wreck right now I do a four
ounce rate of trim it and so I'm
adjusting those pgrs to help keep my
clipping volume where I want it to be
when I'm in that ideal range the greens
are fast but they're also recovering
from 26 000 rounds and essentially two
in two months and so that's where I'm
trying to balance is get that growth
rate where it needs to be use the pgr as
a tool to help me stay in that range
okay so let me make sure I got this
right
um a new does has some rate restriction
issues in your mind that might prohibit
you from raising the rate to get more
inhibition
um actually is more of Primo like on
Primo you're stuck in a five and a half
ounce per acre rate on greens there is a
little bit of text below that allows you
to increase or change that rate slightly
but in order to really see a dramatic
increase in suppression from say Primo
you'd have to be up at three quarters of
an ounce which is six times labor rate
and we've done that research it doesn't
kill the grass everything's fine but
instead of 20 suppression you get 40
suppression that's the same amount of
suppression you get out of trim it at a
high rate so okay you know again okay
but then the question comes why mix it
why not just use you know I mean I know
guys that'll put on Fairways they'll put
24 ounces to trim it uh per acre right
well you can and so one thing that you
might see some phytotoxicity although
all these products can be phytotoxic as
you start to get your growth rate to be
too low and so that's a concern but
sometimes you can't go at that high of a
rate legally and so if you're stuck at
that rate then you can do that that that
mix uh other times too like if I'm doing
a root application I'll use the trim it
in there and then if I come back a week
later with full years for disease I'll
throw just be a new in and so I can you
know layer those products as needed and
like that that craft View and green
keeper I can then see what the combined
effect of mixing all of those uh dmis
proxy and pgrs together are doing so a
news is it's more tough on the the POA
than your Primo is going to be it's more
similar to like a cut Cutlass than it is
a trim it's kind of right in the middle
so we see about 30 suppression at that
eight to 12 ounce rate wherever you've
seen about 20 or less at a five ounce
rate of Primo so it's a little more like
Primo in in the because in this tweet
um recently uh you know shifting
carbohydrates to plant roots improving
quality that I mean I know that's what
new Farm is saying
um is that is that's because it's an
early blocker like uh like Primo talk to
me a little late blocker both of them
are late blockers
um
if you
you know the the plant's making so much
sugar and so if you're preventing from
unnecessary top growth then you have
more sugar to to drive rooting to to
make it healthy that show the graph you
showed before of bench press where it
just grows like crazy and then the roots
really diminish during the summer a lot
of that is because Bank grass is a
little silly it's it's maximum growth
potential from a clipping perspective
isn't when the average air temperature
is in the upper 70s well from a
physiology perspective it's not making
much sugar at that level so then what
happens is if you over fertilize then
you're pushing all this vertical growth
there's no sugar left over to to dry
root in so that's why in the summer in
this graph here we see a lot of rooting
in the early spring because it doesn't
start making a lot of vertical growth
until it gets into the upper 70s for
average temperatures that's temperatures
and then you know highs of 90. that's
what the bankras likes to grow
vertically
um the PO is on the other side it wants
to grow vertically when the temperatures
are about averaging around 60. so it was
actually on the other side of peak sugar
so when you look at that pace growth
potential that is the potential to make
sugar cool season grasses is around 68
70 degrees average temperature and so as
as those as those growth rates
um deviate from that that's when the
problems start to occur that's why
things like Bank grass and the Carolinas
can't make it through the whole summer
because it loves the the heat it
literally grows itself to death like a
like a dandelion treated with 24d and
that's why if we can use the pgr to
suppress the growth rate keep just
enough growth there to recover from
traffic then we can prolong how much
carbohydrate we have to survive those
stressful periods okay so let's move to
the Future here and
um where you know we want to train the
machine uh to help us with this
um there's two things on my mind before
I am you know get into this even deeper
when you said Anew is between is more
like Cutlass and somewhere between
Cutlass and trim it you like it it's
it's harder on the POA and I think of
Cutlass as easier on the on the bent
grass uh trim it can be pretty nasty to
Bent Grass Cutlass a little easier on
the bent grass you're saying a new if
you're using it sort of to really sort
of keep your POA at Bay or not see it
expand uh you like it as maybe a little
bit more aggressive than Cutlass but not
as aggressive as trim it exactly and the
other thing too about this is this is
why I hate doing any aggressive
cultivation or any even fertility when
the average air temperatures were 60
because the the POA has the competitive
Advantage during those weather events
and so anything you're doing you think
are helping to promote bankras is really
promoting POA because the bank grass is
average temperature for growth is in the
70s and so this time of year I'm trying
to minimize whatever I can do to keep
that competitive POA from taking over
the less competitive event then it's the
summer I'll switch it around more
venting more top dressing literally bury
the Poets of death fertilize more when
the bank price wants to grow and and
encroach on that POA and then use these
pgrs to further weaken that plant
um because it is a little bit harder
than say your Primo would be okay so you
know Carl and I uh and here at Cornell
and our new employee Chase scrubas we're
we're all about being more data driven
and being able to predict these things
um we would like superintendents to be a
little bit more predictive and
anticipatory of these things I know this
has evolved for you and I know Green
keeper is is giving you the platform to
really utilize these things you know I
can look at data and see in an r squared
of of 88 is better than an r squared of
61. talk to me in Practical terms when
you stand up in front of a group of golf
course superintendents and let's assume
they're Northern Golf Course
superintendents
um how do you get them to say well yeah
you can predict why should you even have
to predict this I can measure it bill
you just got me on measuring the damn
thing we're finally getting them to put
it in the bucket and now we're saying
well we can predict it how do you sell
this to folks uh to tell them why
predicting this is going to give them
some a bit of an advantage because when
you're sitting there making those
decisions as to do I need to fertilize
or how much pgr do I need to put in the
tank today do I need to mix mix those
pgrs together to get more or less
suppression should I use a more
aggressive or less aggressive fungicide
you have to make an assumption of well
where is your growth going to go over
the next two to three weeks and if you
don't know you can easily overdo it in
One Direction so from our intuitive
nature of managing golf courses we know
we start getting Frost that growth rate
is going to really die off but say you
didn't know that and you're using your
full summer pgr programs and it's going
to be cold the next three weeks you
would easily over regulate your Turf but
because you know that well we're going
to have some Frost that's going to be
Nature's pgr maybe I'll just use a new
by itself right that's an intuitive
model based on your experience that's
all this is It's just letting the
computer brain bring in more factors
than we can and to just give you a kind
of a little prediction so we're actually
working on building this right now it's
make it's like a graph and it kind of
looks like a the cone of of uh what's
that called on hurricanes to know where
is it gonna hit oh the storm track yeah
the cone of uncertainty exactly code of
uncertainty so we predict where it's
going and then we can kind of show that
in a certainty bro so at least you're
getting some guidance as to expect it to
be going up or down and then that helps
me schedule do I need more or less pgr
or do I need more or less fertilizer
should I maybe hold off on cultivation
or maybe I need to get some sand out
next week because I think it's going to
grow like crazy that's important
guidance to help craft your program
along and ultimately maintain your
choice performance well and it all and
this and thank you for that perfect last
line Turf performance at the end of the
day the golf course superintendents are
going to be judged on the performance of
those surfaces right and you've got this
really nice functioning green keeper
where you know you take some green speed
measurements you give it a simple Turf
quality you collected a little bit of
clippings uh we are regularly getting
soil moisture uh surface firmness a lot
of this stuff we're going to get out of
the GS3 moving forward it's hopefully uh
you know in the future we're going to
see a lot more integrated platforms
because right now you know you guys and
Deacon are sort of at the head of the
game here I think ultimately this is
what guys want to do how hard is this to
do Bill do you get a lot I mean you have
a lot of users now on Greenkeeper a lot
of Premium users that might be beginning
to Embark about on this
um I know you've really been working on
getting these performance measurements
and then ultimately predictions moving
forward what's the adoption been about
this uh use of this for performance and
and ultimately what are some of the
things that you've learned so far with
guys that are using it I think I'd say
don't knock it till you try it everybody
that it's one of those things like you
say uh Doug so that I would say if uh
you use a TDR meter and you don't like
it I'll buy it back from you and he's
never bought one back it's one of those
things too where once people start
entering their clipping data and even
their green speed data every day it
becomes a habit and it becomes really
powerful and useful to understand they
need to roll more they need a double cut
can they maybe skip a mowing and so
that's an immediately practical aspect
of it by tracking clippings every day we
know what the end of year clipping
yields look like therefore we can
predict how much fertilizer you've
removed to make sure that your additions
are roughly equal to your removal to
make sure you're being efficient and
then again we get that guidance as to
what do we need to do from a management
perspective to either manipulate growth
rate so I mean writing this down you'll
quickly figure out where that value is
and so people that have been doing this
they see the the value of two minutes a
day to then help make a better
management decisions okay because what
I'm hoping for much like the machine
learning part is that this is also going
to help the machine that on any given
day you'll be able to say if I've done
this and the weather conditions are this
and
um this is a pretty typical day that I'd
see I can expect these greens to perform
like this I'm assuming this is then
going to give us a lot of confidence uh
overall in in not even having to take
the data forever because the machine
will have learned a bit yep and it's
done in your course and we've actually
improved upon this Frank a couple weeks
ago now where you can before you go to
this page you've optionally enter
management data how much irrigation
mowing height did you mow did you roll
did you double roll how many hours has
it been since that from when you took
the measurements all of those are going
to be important pieces to let the site
know how does your green speed respond
to double mowing versus single Mowing
and so those are some of the the big
things that we're doing with the machine
learning and so we have two developers
working on that right now for the summer
and then my other developer is working
on the GPS sprayer map feed features so
if you have a GPS sprayer you need to
edit your boundaries group them
differently you can import them right
into Greenkeeper edit them and then
export them right back to your sprayer
and that's been a big limitation in the
hardware is there we needed the software
and we're hoping to launch that in the
next couple of weeks here to pull in all
that spatial data and edit those GPS for
your Maps well we're all in we're
getting the frost spray unit on our uh
sprayer here for Chris and Todd at the
rtj and I'm looking forward to getting
the sensor hooked up on the mower I know
that there's another company doing this
as well so I'm really pleased and you
know not that you need competition but
in general I'm really pleased that this
is becoming more mainstream we got off
the hype of drones and now we're back on
to actually measuring things on the
ground um
years before I let you go and Carl I
think we can take a minute for questions
um how's the fencer been working
preliminarily what's your we've used it
for five years and um in Michael Carlson
my PhD student who now works for our
company
um he showed that we reduce fertility by
80 at my golf course which is relative
to what my standard Fairway program
would have been uh we only fertilize
when we need to we can do variables
prescription maps with our variable rate
sprayer uh and so those years we've
reduced by 80 percent one year we didn't
fertilize Fairways at all when you're
managing Ben grass Fairways that's
important you don't want to have thatch
accumulation and so it's really helped
me to uh to look for Trends look for
areas that need more fertilizer like
your collars or your approaches or
specific collars and just Target those
and so this whole
um geospatial view will help your
sensors come into you or you're making
the bracket right now I have um about a
dozen more that are unaccounted for so
anyone out there wants some active
sensors on their mowers please uh email
me and we'll we can get you set up
um so that you can be bringing in that
type of growth data from your Fairway
unit and yeah you know like you said
earlier the 30 acre Fairways right when
Bill when you say you can't fertilize it
that much that's music to our ears right
Carl and it's and it's not just the
environment and we come at it from sort
of a water quality environmental
perspective but that's costs right that
is money you can spend elsewhere in your
operation right bill and the other the
other thing on the uh the sprayer
savings is yeah this the percentage of
savings on Fairways is less because
they're bigger areas bigger polygons but
it's a larger square footage right so
greens might save 30 of three acres
that's small square footage Fairways is
10 of 30 Acres that's a lot of savings
so if you are looking to like buy these
Technologies if you're talking to your
greens committee think about those two
different metrics There's an actual
total acreage saved or there's a
percentage saved and you know use the
one that's best to help sell well it
pays for itself pretty quick bill I mean
once you get the sensor and you're
talking about 80 reduction on Fairways
and I'm you know every time I fertilize
I'm treating three to four acres less I
pay for that sensor pretty quick right
Carl
yeah and you pay for the GPS but I mean
if you're using if you're a high-end
sort of application golf course you can
pay for these things in literally a year
and a half like that's how much you can
and there's also the intangibles the
performance side it's not just the
savings the grass looks better we spray
our collars
um and approaches separately from our
greens we don't have collar decline
issues anymore as a result from pgr
stacking on collars that alone justify
the cost you know you can talk about
fertilizer savings all day but when my
collars are alive and I'm not getting
pressure from you know my greens
committee or my city manager why is this
looking this way that is worth it and so
there's all kinds of intangibles on top
of those those fertilizer savings and
when I do say 80 my normal program would
have been about like eight hundredths of
a pound every two weeks and so that's
what it would have been if I would have
just you know scheduled it out yeah Bill
thanks for taking the time it's yeah I
really appreciate it I know you're busy
as hell we juggling a lot of things
instead of greenkeeperap.com seven day
free trial register if any questions
helping keeperapp.com to reach us and uh
and thank you for the opportunity to
talk on your podcast today anytime
anytime Carl we're ready to go yeah it's
uh this year it's been a longest 30
minutes in Turf maybe
uh that's me it's an extra 10 minutes I
think it's well worth it today so
everybody take care we'll see you guys
tomorrow uh John Soraka tomorrow sports
turf so uh talking FIFA FIFA yeah FIFA
maybe Super Bowl I don't know
everybody take care this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu